hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his piece technologies of the self
michel foucault
is outlining four distinct
types of what he's calling technologies
and he's using the word in a very broad
sense here i also want to point out that
he's
not attempting to provide a theory of
technology
per se the essence of technology as such
he's also not attempting to provide an
exhaustive
uh you know typology of all
forms of technology in part because
his listing and distinction is
motivated by a set of interests
and and uh you could call them
directions of research on his
part so this comes up in the section
context of study
and he says my objective for more than
25 years has been to
sketch out a history
of the different ways in our culture
that humans develop knowledge
about themselves so the the orientation
for technology in this case and the
four types that he's going to
distinguish are motivated by that
that particular research orientation or
project and he says you know what are
these different ways
in our culture that humans develop
knowledge about themselves
economics biology psychiatry medicine
and penology and if you think about the
structure of his his works in general
um particularly the the earlier and
middle
books that he's he's publishing well
those are
you know focused on on these issues and
he goes on and says
the main point is not to accept this
knowledge at face value but to
analyze these so-called sciences
as very specific truth games related to
specific techniques
that human beings use to understand
themselves so there's
you know what we can call in general
hermeneutics of suspicion
which doesn't mean that everything is
you know turned into a prison or any
sort of the nonsense that people bring
up
with respect to foucault he's interested
in differentiating out
how these different as he's calling them
here in quotes truth games
operate and how they connect up with
everything else that we find
interesting and valuable so he says
as a context we must understand
there's four major types of these
there's the key term
these technologies right he's not saying
four major types of technology
per se he's saying four major types of
these technologies
each as he calls it a matrix
of practical reason so we should pause
on that before we go into the typology
what does it mean to say that something
is a
matrix of practical reason now
there's there's two key terms there
right matrix and then practical reason
practical reason practical rationality
is when we distinguish it from say pure
reason or speculative or theoretical
reason
it's about getting things done and this
is this is a notion that goes
all the way back in the west to say
aristotle right aristotle distinguished
between
practical and theoretical he also talked
about poetic
meaning productive activities and this
is a very important
distinction for him he even talks about
there being
you know truth uh in different senses
right
uh truth in in this is the nick of
mccain ethics book six
truth in the practical sense has to do
not just with what we would
call truth and falsity but also with
what we ought to do and what we ought
not to do what is
choice-worthy what is to be rejected
what is good for us what's not you know
what's bad for us
all those sorts of things so practical
reason encompasses this
jumping ahead say to somebody like kant
you know when he has the critique of
practical reason
it's really a critique a reasoned
examination so reason is examining
itself
of how we are motivated to do things and
whether they are truly moral
or not what ends we ought to be adapting
it's also
providing knowledge about ourselves all
these discourses of practical reason do
provide us with
knowledge of what what kind of things we
are partial knowledge right because
it turns out we're incredibly complex
and so practical reason
how should we do things what sort of
reasoning process should we follow how
do we select between different ends
how do we set up hierarchies of goods or
bads how do we establish lines that we
won't cross
what do we do after we've crossed them
all of those are questions for
practical reason and in talking about
matrices i'm not going to get you know
very etymological here you know matrix
means womb or anything like that
but we do want to say it's not just
about you know matrices and say linear
algebra for logistics
we're talking about how complex systems
are put together and in a certain sense
one of the technologies technologies
assign systems
does in fact encompass all of these
insofar as we
represent them right so these matrices
interpenetrate with each other
so let's talk about the four different
kinds now let's run through them very
quickly
he says technologies of production
technologies of sign systems
technologies of power and technologies
of the self now what are these let's
take a look at each of these
uh he doesn't he doesn't give us a very
long discussion of any of them
except for technologies itself which the
entire piece is about
of course right but uh they're all
they're all worth thinking about so what
are what are technologies
of production he says these permit us to
produce
transform or manipulate things so you
know
generating a book involves technologies
of
production now it also involves sign
systems but let's put that aside for the
moment
think about the physicality of this
object you know we have a number of
wooden pulp pressed things with
chemical compounds that have bleached
them
and then other chemical compounds
overlaid
on them the ink that that goes into this
or perhaps you know
we could have other things as well they
could be burned into the page they could
be inscribed into the page
we have the whole binding we have the
coloration
of this this is a physical object
so just as much as this chalkboard
is a physical object that had to be
produced the tie that i'm
wearing i'm sure is mass produced
according to some
pattern that a designer picked out
and somebody okayed and then said all
right we're gonna
what kind of what is this thing made out
of it's uh 100
silk that's why it has to be dry clean
only apparently on the tag i wonder if
the tag is 100
silk or made of it's probably made of
some sort of plasticky material because
it feels that way
and all of this goes into technologies
of production now you know we could have
an
earlier time in which the fabric that
this tie was made of
was produced by hand and then it was
dyed by hand you know
cravats have been around for quite a
long time before they started being
mass produced so there's there's other
ways of producing transforming
manipulating
things we might include logistics to
some degree
in there as well getting things from
place to place
you know this this time made its way to
the
i believe men's warehouse where we
bought it or maybe we bought it online i
don't really quite remember where we got
it from
but all of that would be within the
technologies
of production then we have technologies
of
sign systems he says these
permit us to use signs meanings symbols
or
signification so very broad stuff
concerned with communication
concerned with naming concerned with
reference concerned with
uh telling people you know again
practical reason telling people what to
do
setting out checklists a grocery list is
in part
a you know technology of production
tells you what to do
go get some pineapples go get some
canned beans
but it's also being carried out through
the technologies of sign
systems right and we we could include
not just the actual writing itself or
the
the verbiage or concepts but the paper
again use the book right now this book
is part of a technology of sign
systems a vast technology as it turns
out
and we might consider the video or
podcast or web page to be part of that
as as well i mean in a certain sense you
are producing something but it's also
significative right and
we could talk about what does it mean
that i'm wearing
a tie what does it mean that i'm wearing
a tie that i don't really know
you know it's provenance to even talk
about providences
for ties is that an appropriate word
technologies of sign
systems right so that's you know pretty
straightforward
foucault is not saying anything i think
that's particularly controversial and
bringing these things up then he goes on
and says technologies of power this is
one of the things that he's
particularly interested in throughout
his career even going back to you know
my objective for more than 25 years
technologies of power which determine
the conduct of individuals and submit
them to certain
ends or domination and objectivizing
of the subject so making you do things
right
when i set up my class sites for my
online
students i am setting up in some
respects
something that's a technology of science
systems also technology production
but it's also a technology of power i'm
going to make them
hopefully read certain texts
and respond to them in say discussion
forums
and then engage with each other's
responses
and ideally produce some reflection and
learning on their
their part right and i'm using power
if they don't do it then i give them a
bad grade and you know some students
discover
later on that there's an awful lot of
work for them that they haven't yet
done and you know sometimes they get
quite a oh you're using power on me
sometimes they're very apologetic
all of that is part of essentially a
technology of power
and there's many different ways in which
this plays out like i said foucault's
career was largely oriented around
showing that power is involved even when
we we may not
see it and then we have technologies of
the self
so why bring this up so
it's providing us with something
additional
here he says technologies of the self
which permit
individuals bought to effect by their
own means
or with the help of others very
important qualification there
it's not just like entirely
bootstrapping on your own part or having
illuminations going off and you know
facing the wall and meditating for 10
years
you do most of this through consulting
others
having others involved the others help
you
with these technologies of the self
to to carry out a number of
operations on themselves on
things that belong to them their own
bodies and souls
thoughts conduct and way of being or we
might say
lifestyle relationships also fit in with
us
so that's very important here we're
talking about a difference between
technology of power
power is used on you to make you do
things technology is itself
you are determining yourself
in certain ways to make you do things or
change or hold on to what you've you've
changed too
and it's to attain a certain state
now he gives some examples here these
are not the only possible ones to attain
a certain state of happiness
purity wisdom perfection or
immortality so there's a lot of
different
possible ends involved with the
technologies itself i think it's worth
dwelling on what he doesn't say
our potential ends you know
entertainment
being interested in in things
uh keeping yourself from feeling like
you're dead inside okay those
could maybe fit into that but those
aren't things that
he talks about here notice he also
doesn't say like you know getting ahead
in life
being successful having a lot of social
media followers any
anything like that obviously social
media didn't exist when when foucault
was around but
you know celebrity certainly did he was
a celebrity
so we have these four different
technologies
and as he points out um
these four types of technologies hardly
ever function
separately although each of them he says
is associated with a certain type of
domination
now this brings up a really interesting
point
aren't technologies of the self like
anti-domination
you know they're good and technology is
a power they're bad right
and then the other two are maybe like
neutral depending on how we use them
fouco does not buy into that at all
whether they're good or bad really
depends on the perspectives that we're
taking
on them and technologies of the self do
involve a certain domination you are
dominating
yourself very often it's framed in in
you know
ancient philosophy and medieval
philosophy and theology and
spiritual practices as a better part of
yourself
is using the self to dominate the worst
parts
of yourself right you can think about
the platonic
rational part and theomonic part aligned
against the
the unruly appetites in the republic or
in other
texts right we could go on and on from
there so they all do involve
domination they all do involve we might
also say
exploitation or subordination in certain
ways
so he says each implies certain modes of
training
and modification of individuals not only
the obvious sense of acquiring certain
skills
also in the sense of acquiring certain
attitudes and he gives the example
in karl marx's capital he says the
relation between manipulating things in
domination appears clearly
there where every technique of
production requires modification of
individual conduct not just skills like
learning how to operate a machine but
also attitudes
looking at the the day as you know the
the work hours
which belong to the employer and then
the little bit of leisure time that you
get after you come home and crash
right to get up to do it again every one
of these
production sign systems power self
involves domination involves
transformation of people think about
sign systems
getting people to actually learn a
language
is involving a lot of domination you
know the kid
points at the cat and says doggy and
you're like no no no that's a kitty cat
right you are actually changing the kid
you're changing attitudes about it oh
look at the
the good kitty look at the bad kitty and
we could go on and on from from there
so he says the the couple other things
that we want to point out
usually the first two technologies are
used in the study of the sciences and
linguistics it's the last two the
technologies of domination itself which
have most kept my attention
i've attempted a history of the
organization of knowledge with respect
to both domination and the self i
studied madness not in terms of the
criteria of the formal sciences
but to show what type of management of
individuals inside and outside of
asylums
was made possible by this strange
discourse so how
does sign systems like classifications
diagnoses
how do those come together with power
and
how does the discourse of power also
lead in some cases at least
to not just your nuts were going to lock
you up and experiment on you but we
we want you to be a better person we
want you to recover
your genuine self that has been lost
that has been alienated from you there's
also a technology of itself being
brought about there as well and so he he
says that
i call governmentality the encounter
between the technologies of domination
of others
and those of the self when these are
coming together
and he says perhaps i've insisted too
much on the technology
of domination and power i'm more
interested more and more interested in
the interaction between oneself and
others
and in technologies of individual
domination in the mode of action that an
individual exercises
on himself by means of the technologies
of the self
so the technologies of the self are what
foucault
comes to realize at the end he's really
interested in and this is part of what
he has to offer
uh in this essay and throughout his his
later works
uh looking at models
for how people in the past developed
these technologies itself and applied
them
and what results were and then thinking
about how
we might do them the same or differently
in the present the last thing i'll say
you never get technologies of the self
without all of these other things being
involved right so you're never going to
have a pure
discourse of the technology of the self
self transformation
self understanding care of the self that
doesn't already
you know involve in multiple ways these
other
discourses and from foucault's
perspective that's okay because he's not
a puritan
trying to entirely extricate or liberate
the technologies of the self from
all of these others it's not as if the
technologies itself are intrinsically
good and technologies of power are
intrinsically bad as we pointed out
earlier
they kind of go hand in hand with each
other
you